in the Sahara Desert there stands a
strange monument marking the place where
once the most isolated tree in the world
stood the Tenere wastelands were once
populated by a rich forest of acacia
trees by the 20th century all but one
had been wiped out the story of the last
tree of ténéré is short sad and stupid
this tree had roots that ran 40 feet
deep and was surrounded on all sides by
400 kilometers of nothing but sand when
a British officer came upon it in 1939
he exclaimed you have to see this tree
to believe him he didn't understand why
camels hadn't come and eaten its leaves
where the locals hadn't chopped it down
and used it for firewood he said this
tree was a kind of miracle and must also
be sacred to the people who lived there
and it was and marked a place on Caravan
routes and was treated as a sacred
symbol of life in the desert but it
didn't stand the rest of the 20th
century quite as well and in 1973 a
drunk Libyan truck driver ran headfirst
into the tree despite having 400
kilometers on either side to go around
it nonetheless into the tree he went
broke it clean off and in that instant
the last tree of ténéré was no more once
called the most remote tree in the world
it still managed to be hit by a drunk
driver so in its place today there is a
kind of weird metal fake tree used to
mark the spot and honor its existence
but it is a poor replacement for this
tiny beautiful sliver of life
that once flourished in the otherwise
empty desert subscribe here and watch
more videos here can you freaking
imagine driving across the desert and
hitting literally the only thing you
could hit